ceux des prix en janvier +0 3% se met
communiste à madrid début mars marchait
carillo berling were peut être corbalan
18 ans de réclusion pour le tueur à la
504 les jurés ont voté les circonstances
atténuantes
gaston defferre en direct de marseille
pour le journal d'antenne 2 une recette
pour sauver l'om
mesdames messieurs bonsoir il y a les
surprises des bonnes et des mauvaises
surprises bien le taux de la hausse des
prix en janvier en est une bonne 0,3
pour cent même les experts optimistes
avaient prévu 0,5
la cgt qui calcule autrement avait
annoncé 0,9 pour cent
monsieur raymond barre vient de marquer
un point dans sa lutte contre
l'inflation
deux mois de suite en effet les prix
n'ont augmenté que de 0,3 pour cent
pourvu que cela dure direz vous et les
commentateurs ajouteront très vite que
l'image politique du premier ministre se
trouvera par conséquent renforcer en
tout cas monsieur raymond barre et
palais il ya quelques minutes à peine
comme il le fait chaque semaine par le
président de la république
cette fois il lui a présenté lundi ce 2
janvier à l'elysée cendrillon fall isme
mais avec une satisfaction qui se lit
assez bien sur son visage vieux onglet
ja c'est à dire que les industriels les
chefs d'entreprise les commerçants ont
appliqué avec beaucoup de détermination
les dispositions relatives à la baisse
la tva
c'est la raison pour laquelle je
voudrais ce soir remercier tous ceux qui
ont concouru au succès de cette
opération et je m'en félicite parce que
contrairement à certaines rumeurs qui
sait pète répandue au cours de ces
derniers jours
la politique qui est menée va conduire à
une modération des prix en france au
cours de l'année 1977 en plus de
monsieur georges séguy ou de monsieur
edmond maire monsieur georges marchais
est sceptique
c'est le moins qu'on puisse dire sur les
chances du plan de redressement barre il
a critiqué aujourd'hui avec une rare
violence et 10 ans à propos du premier
ministre je cite qu'ils pillaient et
dilapider l'argent public au bénéfice
des monopoles je pense que monsieur
raymond bas répondra demain puisqu'il
est en effet l'invité du journal
d'antenne 2 nous aurons l'occasion avec
lui de parler de la situation économique
et sociale
monsieur bergeron est ce que l'on peut
dire
aujourd'hui vous l'avez entendu
presqu'avec lourd que monsieur raymond
barre marque des points est ce que vous
le sentez aussi
oui incontestablement et je ne suis pas
de ceux qui regretteront le fait que
monsieur bart et marqué un point dans le
domaine de la lutte contre l'inflation à
moins d'être fou je ne vois pas très
bien qui pourrait souhaiter l'inflation
l'augmentation des prix avec toutes les
conséquences que cela peut comporter
dans tous les domaines cela dit j'ai
conscience que la bataille contre
l'inflation qui n'est pas une bataille
en france qui est une bataille
universelle est loin d'être gagnée dans
la mesure où le problème a une dimension
internationale dans la mesure où tout le
monde sait que les économies sont
interdépendantes dans les discussions
monsieur bergeron qui concerne 7 million
et demi de fonctionnaires et qui sont
ouvertes aujourd'hui entre les syndicats
et monsieur migaud est ce que vous allez
en tenir compte vous même écouter les
revendications qui aime forcément compte
de l'évolution des prix
puisque vous savez qu'un des points
controversés des contrats de ces
dernières années sont les clauses de
progression de pouvoir d'achat est
également évidemment des clauses qui
garantissent de pouvoir d'achat par
conséquent dans la mesure où l'inflation
est moins forte
les négociateurs tienne compte des
réalités mais entre nous est-ce que vous
êtes surpris vous même de des résultats
de 2.380 23% encore une fois sans crier
victoire trop vite
non ce qu'ils peuvent d'une certaine
manière surprendre c'est que on a
semble-t-il appliquer les répercussions
de la tva on les a respectés dans dans
les prix pour monsieur michel rolland de
la cfdt qui s'est confié à témoignage
chrétien ce soir raymond barre ne
dialogue pas il impose est ce que c'est
votre avis mais chez bach n'est pas un
homme facile je suis bien pour le placé
pour le savoir
étant donné que nous sommes en désaccord
à l'heure actuelle sur la poursuite de
la politique contractuelle et jeudi un
monsieur raymond barre attention il
n'est pas de démocratie sans dialogue
social permanent est ce que je redoute
c'est une sorte de paralysie de la vie
sociale qui ferait que pendant 1 c
un temps il n'y aurait plus de
discussions entre les syndicats les
patrons l'état les directions des
entreprises d'internaliser aujourd'hui
la politique contractuelle continue elle
continue il ya des discussions dans les
entreprises nationalisées
les discussions ont commencé aujourd'hui
dans la fonction publique et je constate
que une certaine évolution s'est déjà
manifestée dans les discussions dans le
secteur nationalisé je ne veux pas
préjuger de ce qui se passera dans la
fonction publique merci monsieur
bergeron et demain nous ferons par un
monsieur bart de vos préoccupations mais
dites lui bien parce que c'est important
cette affaire de blocage de la vie
sociale beaucoup plus qu'ils l'imaginent
suivi dix rangs lyonnais ce soir dans le
journal de 20h le parti communiste
espagnol n'est pas encore légalisé
son chef gilles santiago carillo n'a pas
moins inviter à madrid
georges marchais et enrick obert lingway
le rendez vous est pris pour les 2 et 3
mars
leur objectif définir en quelque sorte
leur communisme il n'est pas impossible
que le chilien luis corvalan les
rejoignent cela se négocie en ce moment
c'est un premier ministre israélien avec
une autorité renforcée que le président
giscard d'estaing accueillera bientôt en
visite officielle à paris sans doute à
la fin du mois de mai au tout début du
mois de juin qui sera accra binh chef du
gouvernement de tel aviv vient d'être
réélu à la tête du parti travailliste
israélien une victoire que l'on peut
interpréter comme le feu vert de son
parti pour la conférence de genève sur
le proche orient
cet homme qu'on applaudit à la tribune
c'est itzhak rabin le premier ministre
israélien qui vient de remporter de
justesse la victoire
si les délégués l'ont élu c'est qu'il ne
voulait pas mettre leur premier ministre
en difficulté dans une phase de
négociations au proche-orient mais
monsieur shimon peres son rival obtient
tout de même un solide soutien moral
à défaut d'une victoire politique ainsi
monsieur rabin va se présenter en solide
position devant le président carter à
washington le mois prochain mais sa
réélection ne calme pas les querelles
entre colombes et faucons au moment où
l'on parle de 77 comme l'année de la
paix pour les travaillistes c'est aussi
le début du compte à rebours avant les
législatives du 17 mai prochain
leur victoire est loin d'être assurée il
espère pourtant avoir assez de sièges
pour former un nouveau gouvernement de
coalition
andré amalric a passé une partie de sa
journée au palais du luxembourg il a été
très heureux c'est son mot de son
entretien avec les sénateurs du groupe
de l'union centriste les amis de
monsieur lecanu et andré amalric sera
dans quelques jours en allemagne
fédérale
le son se lier schmitt ne le reverra pas
ou ne rencontrera pas mais il a demandé
à l'un de ses collaborateurs de
s'entretenir avec l'historien soviétique
dissidents les changes
amalric georges marchais auquel vous
avez assisté en direct mardi dernier et
dans tout cas a commenté un peu partout
et par les intéressés eux mêmes
à l'issue du comité central de son parti
monsieur marche est dit et ce matin en
ce qui concerne la défense des libertés
qu'ils avaient les mains propres
c'est votre avis monsieur poniatowski et
lorsque l'on entend prononcer les mots
de parti communiste et de liberté on est
toujours conduit à sourire si monsieur
merchet les mains propres
je pense qu'il faut qu'il continue à se
laver les mains tous les jours et aussi
concerne monsieur amalric que vous
évoquez tout à l'heure la france a un
très vieille tradition d'accueil des
réfugiés politiques
cette tradition et la maintient
aujourd'hui ils ont des réfugiés
chiliens portugais espagnols seulement
ces réfugiés doivent respecter une
certaine attitude subi ni l'état on
comprend peut-être que le président de
la république
ne pas répondu à la demande d'audience
d'amalric dont on comprend moins
qu'aucun ministre du gouvernement le lui
ai accordé une audience en nous sommes
un pays de liberté monsieur amalric a eu
accès à tous les journaux aux radios et
aux télévisions
il n'y avait aucune raison que monsieur
le président la république accepte
l'exigence de dater deux heures présenté
par mathieu amalric
mais ce que ça veut dire que la raison
d'état en poche dans certaines
circonstances de dire où et quand les
droits de l'homme sont menacés non pas
du tout il a eu l'occasion pleinement de
le dire sur toutes les ondes françaises
la télévision et la presse
j'ajoute en tout cas son retour d'israël
monsieur françois mitterrand a déclaré
cet après midi qu'il comprenait
parfaitement l'attitude du président de
la république celui ci traite d'état et
ça dit monsieur françois mitterrand et
non pas avec des particuliers après le
conseil politique
les républiques indépendantes je connais
trop ce qui vous est félicité des
conditions dans lesquelles la majorité à
préparer les élections municipales en
province et vous avez rêvé un peu plus
tard que monsieur bart sera le moment
venu l'animateur le coordinateur le
coordonnateur de la majorité petite
phrase qui est passée inaperçue qui
donnera les investitures si j'ai bien
compris monsieur bart et bien se passera
comme cela s'est toujours passé j'ai moi
même participé avec les premiers
ministres et encore avec monsieur
messmer il ya trois ans à la
détermination des investitures c'est à
dire que le premier ministre avec des
secrétaires généraux des formations de
la majorité décide de l'octroi des
investitures la majorité et vous avez vu
que le président de la république
l'autre jour à conférer à monsieur bart
le rôle d'animateur de la majorité et
d'animateurs de la compagne de
légistatives c'est donc que ce rôle lui
sera dévolu de la dire donnez-les
investi qu'aucun autre leader de la
majorité ne pourra revendiquer ce type
de chefs ou d'animateur principal de la
majorité le premier ministre est désigné
comme le chef de la majorité c'est pour
atos qui monsieur chirac l'ancien
premier ministre est souvent sa thèse
qui doit y avoir des élections
anticipées car le gouvernement ce
gouvernement ne bénéficient pas de
la légitimité populaire qu'est ce que
vous en pensez qu'est ce que c'est que
la légitimité d'abord le gouvernement
actuel est issu nov notre constitution
issue de nos lois est issu des élections
donc c'est le gouvernement légitime il
n'y a à l'heure actuelle aucune raison
de faire des élections anticipées
la cani de la valeur de notre
constitution c'est précisément de le
donner la stabilité politique d'éviter
les crises trop nombreuses et donc de
donner la durée de l'action politique
cette durée qui est inscrite dans la
constitution comporte des élections à
date fixe et n'y a aucune raison de les
anticiper
j'ai chirac disait l'autre jour que les
rapports du ministère de l'intérieur de
votre ministère démontrer l'intérêt des
français pour le rpr est ce que c'est ce
que dit vraiment vos rapports six
chevaliers de bronze je suis un peu
surpris que monsieur chirac et les
rapports du ministre de l'intérieur vous
le dis très franchement
mais pour répondre à votre question ces
rapports donné trois indications en
effet progression du rpr en décembre
d'un sport à partir de janvier et depuis
trois semaines recule pour vous la
bataille de paris est ce que c'est le
pluralisme organisé ou alors
l'affrontement organisé entre giscardien
rpr non ce devrait être le pluralisme
organisée c'est malheureusement le
pluralisme désorganiser ce qui s'est
passé en province
j'aurais souhaité une voix se réaliser à
paris qu'en province presque partout les
formations de la majorité ont passé un
accord et vend en sont là l'affrontement
électorale malheureusement à paris la
candidature monsieur dans l'anneau qui
était le candidat d'union de la majorité
s'est trouvé face à une dictature
décider seul d'ailleurs par monsieur
jacques chirac et cette discorde est
préoccupante
j'espère qu'elle n'aura pas de suite ni
la conséquence monsieur chirac a des
chances d'être maire de paris j'essaye
faut le demander aux électeurs dont
conseil monsieur d'ornano en a je pense
que j'ai dans le noir et je vous ferai
la même réponse le précédemment une
dernière question
on dit souvent sur ces terrains on est
très souvent que
vous intervenez pour des pressions sur
les journalistes et que vous écoutez
beaucoup est ce que c'est vrai en ce qui
concerne les pressions sur les
journalistes que jamais la presse et les
radios et les télévisions n'en était
plus libre et tous les français ont
cette impression de liberté et qui est
vrai qu'il n'ya aucune pression
le même récit conscients les écoutes
téléphoniques en arrivant au ministère
de l'intérieur j'ai constaté qu'il
écoute téléphonique de caractère dit
politique avait augmenté au cours des
précédents rendement légèrement
j'étais visiter le centre j'ai relevé
tout seul qui ne correspondaient pas la
lutte contre la délinquance la
criminalité et je les ai supprimé il ya
eu ainsi suppression de 247 écoutes
téléphoniques et il n'y a pas
actuellement d'écouté téléphonique ni de
politique ni le journaliste ni de
syndicalistes qui craignez-vous le plus
la division de la majorité où la gauche
unie
les deux me paraissent préoccupant je
souhaite nous arrivions à reconstituer
l'union et l'unité de la majorité celle
ci est nécessaire pour faire face à
l'opposition
à ma dernière question sur un autre
thème vous disiez l'autre soir au cours
de l'opération coup-de-poing un canot
ont fait écho qu'il faut neutraliser
amsterdam et on vous répond très souvent
à propos de la drogue
il vaudrait mieux neutraliser les gros
bonnets et les bourbonnais sont
neutralisés celui contre la drogue s'est
fait en trois étapes d'abord on à
démanteler tous les réseaux de
fabrication de la drogue ce qui s'est
passé il ya cinq ou six ans ensuite on a
des manques les les réseaux de commerce
de la drogue par exemple ce qu'on a
appelé la french connection et là
c'était organisé en effet par les
grossistes de la drogue qui étaient des
criminels
ils ont généralement été arrêté et est
condamné actuellement la drogue est un
stade de tout à fait différent ce
qu'assad artisanale de petits commerces
de petits trafics qui serait la médaille
ils sont ma médaille mais par plusieurs
milliers de personnes de drogues et qui
font eux mêmes le commerce de la drogue
qui consomment par ailleurs est-ce qu'on
a des seins paraît de danseuse est un
problème nouveau qu'il est pas seulement
un problème de répression qui est
également un problème de prévention sans
problème
grave que le drogué généralement
psychologiquement dans une situation
humaine difficile
c'est à des adaptations souvent appelée
à dominer il faut faire un effort qui ne
tenait pas du tout uniquement à l'effort
de répression compenser d'encadrement
psychologique que sa propre fille qui a
trick et familiale il vous arrivera
imposé aux hollandais une solution comme
jugement pour mieux lutter contre la
drogue oui nous sommes en train
d'engager une action avec les
gouvernements allemands en particulier
pour faire des démarches communes auprès
du gouvernement allemand au land et
parce que les allemands sont aussi
touchés par exemple ou même vous
remercie il ya en france des milliers
d'armes de guerre en état de marche
lorsqu'elles sont vendus à des
collectionneurs elles sont inoffensives
démilitarisé comme on dit pourtant c'est
une de ses armes un pistolet de
collection qui a tué l'autre jour le
prince de breuil que rue des dardanelles
de personnes vient d'être inculpé le
vendeur et l'officier qui devrait
contrôler la neutralisation de 7 à un
contrôleur général de l'armée inculpé
pour infraction sur les armes à feu en
compagnie d'un armurier monsieur jacques
gary contraint de fermer sa boutique
dans la banlieue de parcs les armes
fasciné se vendent bien
on reproche aux commerçants la vente
illégale d'armes et bien sûr leur
détention d armes que nous avons vendu
qui sont incriminés
ce sont des armes de huitième catégories
telles que celles ci elles sont
neutralisés par une groupie mais
canadiens 6 et le percuteur est à raser
ou enlever pour empêcher la percussion
ces armes là ont été présentés
à l'établissement technique de bourges
pour être contrôlés ne pas avoir de
problèmes par la suite
c'est pourtant perçu que c'est une des
armes que vous avez vendu qu'à servait à
tuer le prince de breuil alors est ce
que vous pensez vous qui êtes un
professionnel
des armes que l'on peut ensuite modifier
un pistolet dans le genre de celui que
vous avez devant vous pour tuer
quelqu'un
la chose est sûre si vous lui étant
donné qu'avec un mot fuck you de
chauffage central on arrive à faire un
fusil ou bricoler quelque chose on peut
se demander aussi où vous trouver les
armes que vous vendez et s'il n'y en a
pas quelques unes qui passe sous le
contrôle a absolument tort puisque elle
rentrer de l'étranger la plupart et elle
rentre avec autorisation si ce sont des
armes de 4e catégorie où elle rentre en
huitième catégorie est contrôlé par des
douanes et 4e catégories faut une
attestation qui est délivrée par le
ministère d une autorisation qui est
délivrée par le ministre des armées
alors une dernière question comment se
fait-il que vous soyez inculpé alors que
vous appliquez la législation pour moi
c'est aberrant je ne comprends pas ça
était mineure la maison me tombe sur la
tête moi peut-on penser monsieur gary
que vous êtes un trafiquant d'armes
absolument pas forcément que la
législation est mal faite
après claire peut-être pas clair non
plus pour le président du jardin du
syndicat des armuriers qui considère que
n'importe quel bricoleur est capable de
rendre à une arme déclassé sa vocation
première
selon lui sa préoccupation est partagée
par le ministre de l'intérieur et le
ministre des armées
un projet de neutralisation définitive
des armes de guerre serait actuellement
à l'étude aura bientôt les réponses
fusent et monsieur bourges au ministère
de la défense qui s'en occupe
les maires prétendent souvent qu'ils ne
peuvent pas faire ce qu'ils veulent pour
leur commune pour certains c'est
peut-être un alibi
un bon moyen de se décharger de leurs
responsabilités mais parfois c'est vrai
l'administration trop lourd trop
imposante les gènes dans leurs
initiatives
deux exemples ce soir tours et colombes
à tour en 1965 la municipalité souhaite
créer sur 200 hectares située sur
l'ancienne commune de saint symphorien
un nouveau quartier et une cité de 5000
logements
mêlant le locatif hlm
à l'accession à la propriété un nouvel
urbanisme admis par tout le monde sauf
par l'administration celle ci a prévu
des règles d'urbanisation
il faut les respecter sinon le
financement par l'état n'est pas acquis
si nous avions voulu respecter le bilan
financier
l'équilibré entre les recettes revente
des terrains par la ville à l'office hlm
et des dépenses que nous avons réalisés
pour acheter les terrains
nous aurions dû construire d'une manière
beaucoup plus dense que celle que vous
voyez ici c'est à dire qu'au lieu
d'avoir des immeubles à trois étages
nous aurions dû pratiquement doubler le
nombre des étages c'est à dire arriver à
six niveaux
mais du même coup la densité du nombre
de logements auraient été trop forte par
rapport à l'étendue de la cour
intérieure et nous avons voulu garder un
équilibre entre la hauteur des immeubles
la surface des courts et la surface des
rues et du même coup la ville a accepté
de participer à la différence de
financement entre le coût des terrains
et bien entendu le coût total un montant
total des recettes que nous avons
encaissés en revendant les terrains à
l'office municipal la réglementation en
vigueur en 1965 ne prévoit en effet
guère d'interprétation il faut tant
d'états jetant d'habitants à l'hectare
telle largeur de rue pour bénéficier des
subventions et crédits d'état à tour la
municipalité et s'est créé elle-même par
ses choix des difficultés alors sur un
coût total de 8 milliards de francs
la ville devra en prendre près de 3 à
son compte il lui faudra emprunter
auprès des banques et notamment des
banques étrangères
au total dix ans auront été nécessaires
pour achever le projet disant parce que
tous les dossiers remonte à paris et que
c'est dans la capitale que se décide en
dernier ressort la hauteur des hlm sur
les bords de la loire
c'est dans la décentralisation des
décisions administratives financières et
techniques
que réside l'avenir il faut que le
préfet de département
c'est les services qui l'entourent
puissent directement prend des décisions
en fonction des demandes et ville et
d'autre part il faut que les villes
obtiennent une globalisation des crédits
d'emprunt et des grilles subventions
pour pouvoir mieux réaliser leurs
efforts financiers et le planifier dans
le temps voilà les deux formules qui
améliorerait les rapports entre les
villes et l'état en attendant chaque
année sur les feuilles d'impôts locaux
la cité de saint symphorien représente
quelques dizaines de francs à colombes
c'est un problème différent que la
municipalité s'est trouvé confronté un
énorme dossier s'étalant sur trois ans
colombe est l'une des 80 villes de
france où l'éducation nationale a fait
construire un lycée et un crs semblables
sinon identiques aux crs paillon lorsque
la tragédie éclatent à paris
l'inquiétude apparaît chez les parents
d'élèves de ces établissements mais
pourtant en dépit du drame
c'est un dialogue de sourds qui s'engage
entre la municipalité de colombes et
l'administration
la première veut la prévention la
seconde souhaite améliorer la détection
et l'évacuation en cas d'un centre de
commissions de sécurité en commission de
sécurité
le dossier progresse trois ans seront
tout de même nécessaire pour que le
problème soit réglé
la lourdeur et difficultés
administratives tienne tu en difficulté
financière au manque de crédit et les
choses sont liées parce que vous savez
que dans beaucoup d'équipement si vous
n'avez pas la subvention de l'état
vous ne pouvez pas obtenir l'emprunt
vous ne pouvez pas réellement commencer
les travaux et le pouvoir politique s'il
voulait pourrait très bien léger cette
bureaucratie en allégeant les
réglementations et en en faisant
notamment les contrôles a posteriori et
non pas avant la réalisation des
dossiers
compte tenu que il y à une
réglementation cette réglementation il
faut la connaître et la respecter et si
elle n'est pas respectée dans le
contrôle a posteriori il ya les élus
doivent d'en porter la responsabilité
des réunions sans fin des lettres par
dizaines des centaines de documents un
symbole peut-être des relations entre
administration et municipalités lorsque
les finances publiques entre en jeu
méprise méprise ou geste de colère le
pdg d'une entreprise de daumazan dans le
gard a tiré sur cinq de ses ouvriers ce
matin l'un d'eux est sérieusement blessé
à l'oeil
les ouvriers étaient en grève et
occupent et l' usine le pdg a déclaré
aux gendarmes qu'ils croyaient avoir
affaire à des voleurs il est toujours
gardé à vue jean baptiste dorkel le
tueur à la 504 a été condamné à 18 ans
de réclusion criminelle par la cour
d'assises du val d'oise
en outre 75 nous avions raconté
l'histoire il avait provoqué la mort
d'une jeune mère de famille en poussant
volontairement sa voiture dans le fossé
après avoir avoué devant les policiers
les magistrats et les journalistes d'or
qu'elle a pratiquement nié pendant tout
son procès jusqu'à ce soir claude
sérillon et oui des dizaines de fois
depuis mardi depuis le début du procès
dont jean baptiste d'or qu'elle a répété
que ce n'était pas lui le coupable que
les autres les témoins et les menteurs
et que les policiers l'avaient menacé
alors lorsque le président roumain qui
dirigeait les débats insistait tantôt
sévère tantôt souriant alors dorkel un
garçon de 21 ans ne se verra amputé du
bras droit de vous presque par défi il
répétait têtu ce n'est pas moi ce n'est
pas moi et puis cet après midi après la
plaidoirie de maître charles l'imam pour
la partie civile après le réquisitoire
de monsieur bras un procureur de la
république à pontoise qui réclamait 20
ans de réclusion criminelle contre ce
forfait abominable son propre terme mais
aussi compte tenu de l'infirmité de
l'accusé de son jeune âge bien l'un des
avocats des doors qu'elle se levait
c'était le bâtonnier millau et faisant
face à son client il lui lançait d'or
qu'elle lève toi tu adorais ton père tu
te souviens des corrections des 30 qu'il
te donnais lorsque tu oublies mentait
alors dis la vérité maintenant est la
réponse tombe un surprenant presse comme
un soulagement
oui je vais vous lire oui c'est moi
brusque changement d'attitude est sans
doute explicable par le caractère à la
limite de la débilité de l'accusé qui ne
sait ni lire ni écrire qu'ils ne
comprenaient pas même les questions qui
lui furent posées tout au long du procès
et puis à signaler que le mari de la
malheureuse victime monsieur mentaux qui
a sollicité une indemnisation ne pourra
pas la toucher du fonds de garantie
automobile car la loi ne prévoit pas que
cette indemnisation s'appliquant qu'à
domicile il faut attendre un décret
d'application d'une autre loi plus
récentes
l'événement de la soirée pour vous qui
regardez antennes de et vous avez raison
c'est le rendez vous que vous donne
jacques chancel avec le prince henri de
danemark et sa famille en direct de
copenhague il vous invite à visiter le
château de christiansborg pour un grand
échiquier royal
la cérémonie spectacle commence après le
journal je suppose où je suis sûr
jacques chancel que vous êtes prêts
parce qu'on entendra mieux le champ tout
à l'heure est ce qu'on entend vous
entendrez je suis sur ce beaucoup mieux
feu jacques chancel tout à l'heure il y
as peut-être un problème de centre le
château de christiansborg
et nous pour le moment oui jacques
chancel
oui nous étions inquiets pour le pour
l'émission de tout à l'heure alors dans
un tel cadre nous vous regardons très
bien avec le prince henri qu est ce que
vous êtes tenus de respecter le
protocole est porté par exemple un
costume spécial
bon nous sommes en ce moment dans le
dans la librairie dans huit halls à la
bibliothèque de la rave au jeudi
librairie parce qu'un anglais ça des
librairies je crois et je vous présente
le prince henrik de danemark qui sera
notre invité ce soir l'invité du grand
échiquier êtes vous prêts etes-vous
prêts monseigneur pour ces trois heures
je suis prêt pour ces trois pour cette
émission qui semble très intéressante où
nous allons présenter un peu du danemark
louis j'espère je pourrais donner avec
vous là un aspect des quelques aspects
culturels de la vie culturelle danoise
nous prétendons pas raconté le danemark
nous allons simplement jeter un regard
sur le danemark ça extrêmement beau
vampire nous avons je prends un
programme qui pourrait plaire qui pourra
plaire qui plaira je le souhaite
nous allons donc jeter un regard sur le
danemark avec
deux grandeurs qu'istres de grands
interprètes et ensuite de très beaux
paysages
j'espère que nous avait bien entendu
parce que moi j'ai ma petite source dans
le rail jean-pierre et j'aurais vous
vois pas ce qui me dérange terriblement
voilà le car nous sommes dans la
bibliothèque de la reine à tout à
l'heure je pense qu'avec le prince henri
qu ici je me souviens bien est
originaire des pyrénées vous parlez
aussi de votre région à ce but
ce but de rouiller à la 53e minute hier
au parc des princes unique mais plein de
promesses personne n'osait croire que la
jeune équipe de michel hidalgo tiendrait
la dragée haute aux champions du monde
en titre les allemands de l'ouest
et pourtant cette victoire est bien là
tout avait commencé par un formidable
exploit technique de michel platini le
match était lancée et bien lancée
les jeunes français de michel hidalgo
quelques 35 sélections à eux on n'avait
pas peur des champions du monde
allemands
plus de trois cent cinquante sélections
les allemandes qui n'était pas venu à
paris pour faire du tourisme
du reste quand on est champion du monde
on a une carte de visite à des fins mais
avec beaucoup de culot un culot
symbolisée par le petit olivier rouyer
ici qui dribble mayer mais qui
malheureusement emmène un peu loin son
ballon avec un culot formidable l'équipe
de france allait petit à petit vaincre
son trac
lacombe obtenait même un bon coup franc
et le stade retenait son souffle michel
platini en a marqué tellement des coups
francs comme celui là
50 cm et mayer aurait été battue ce
n'était que partie remise
lopez le nouveau capitaine lorientais
fort bien le jeu les stéphanois se
montrer brillant platini réussissait un
petit pont est donné à rouiller qui
tirait à côté de leur côté les allemands
tentaient bien de prendre à défaut une
défense où les stéphanois faisait
merveille voilà qui est de bonne augure
à quelques jours de leur rencontre
contre liverpool et rouillée une fois de
plus parfait attendait que janvion
viennent sur sa droite et lui donne une
balle sur le centre de l'arrière
stéphanois platini et à miss échoué d'un
rien
et la mi temps survenait alors que rien
n'avait été marqué mais les occasions
les plus franches avait été français et
le coup de tonnerre intervenait huit
minutes après à la 53e minute exactement
un premier tir de bathenay contre et
olivier rouyer reprend de volée du
gauche
mayer est bâti 23 février 77 le plus
beau jour de la vie d'un jeune joueur de
21 ans olivier rouyer que toute la
france connait match les français des
fanatiques de football en direct de
nancy bonsoir olivier rouyer soir ou
courrier vous après ce but vous vouliez
ça lui a peut-être quelqu'un dans les
tribunes je courais vers but pas alors
pour vous un but de cette façon c'est la
consécration est ce que c'est une simple
promesse ou un merveilleux coup de
chance un coup de bol comme on dit
familièrement
enfin je crois que le bol que vous dites
est une grande importance dans sept à sa
réussite du but mais je crois que le but
il est la récompense pour toute l'équipe
de france qui a mérité vraiment c'est
cette victoire parce que je crois que
depuis deux matches l'un contre la
bulgarie et l'irlande il ya un renouveau
dans le football français c'est tant
mieux pour tout le football
un but de cette nature est ce que ça
change une vie des gens je peux vous
assurer que oui parce que chez moi le
téléphone commence à sonner assez
souvent et ça commence à changer mes
habitudes
et qu'est ce qu'on vous raconte on va me
demande beaucoup de choses au moment des
impressions et c'est sûr tu es aussi
pour me féliciter
j'en remercie beaucoup bien sûr tous les
gens c'est vraiment agréable
alors après ce match du parti des parc
des princes hier soir est ce que vous
êtes assuré de jouer la prochaine
rencontre contre l'irlande
vous savez assuré en lui on le sait pas
parce qu'il peut avoir une blessure où
il ya tellement de concurrence dans le
football français que assuré on est nul
n'est toujours pas mais je crois qu'à
dublin nous avons quelque chose à jouer
la qualification pour la coupe du monde
c'est quelque chose de très important
vous avez repris l'entraînement déjà oui
tout de suite en rentrant j'ai fait un
petit footing en forêt de et puis demain
matin on recommence et puis samedi à
nancy a le choc contre le leader c'est à
dire nantes
vous serez surveiller entouré ya pas de
repos pour les pour les héros merci
olivier rouyer
un résultat qui semble indiquer que le
football français se porte bien au
niveau national en tout cas si certains
clubs comme nantes ou saint-etienne
force est en revanche on ne peut pas en
dire autant de marseille dont la
situation préoccupe la municipalité
monsieur gaston defferre a décidé de
prendre les choses en main une fois de
plus pour l'om il a étudié aujourd'hui
une sorte de plan de sauvetage dont
l'olympique de marseille qui lui a été
proposé par un des collaborateurs
d'agostino alors monsieur de faire
qu'est ce que c'est cette raison qu'elle
est cette raison qui vous fait descendre
en quelque sorte sur la pelouse bien
pour la première fois un certain nombre
d'adhérents de l'om ont décidé de
s'engager sur le plan financier avec
leurs deniers personnels d'une
proportion importante puisqu'il s'agit
de trois millions ils m'ont demandaient
la garantie de la ville pour un emprunt
qui souhaitent également de 3 millions
ça fait combien pour marseille cette
année ça ferait pour marseille cette
année la subvention a été de 750 mille
francs cette fois ci ne s'agit pas d'une
subvention il s'agit d'une garantie
d'emprunt comme mais j'ai le devoir
d'exiger car je dois défendre les
deniers des contribuables que cette
garantie d'emprunt ne joue pas c'est à
dire que je ne vois pas la ville qui
soit amené à payer
est ce que pour autant l'olympique de
marseille est sauvée monsieur de faire
eh bien je crois que l'olympique peut
être sauvé car pour la première fois un
geste positif a été fait par un certain
nombre d'hommes qui ont constitué un
comité de gestion autonome de la section
professionnelle et qui sont décidés à
s'engager personnellement
alors si on comprend bien c'est encore
le maire qui devient capitaine d'équipé
qui descendent sur le terrain non est
normal capé de l'équipe je ne descends
pas sur le terrain mais je fais ce que
j'ai à faire j'ai des devoirs vis-à-vis
de l'om tes devoirs vis-à-vis des
contribuables
je cherche à concilier les deux le geste
qu'ils étaient faits par les adhérents
de l'om commence à me faire penser je
vais examiner le document objet là qui
m'a été en partie cet après midi je vais
faire examiner par mes services
financiers mais ce geste commence à me
faire penser que l'om véritablement être
sauvé je vous ai surtout demandé de
venir en direct avec nous monsieur de
faire parce que c'est un problème qui
touche aussi de nombreux maires de
grandes villes
est ce que pendant longtemps les
municipalités vont avoir à payer sur
l'agent de leurs citoyens de leurs
contribuables des clubs de football qui
sont parfois en détresse et qui appelle
au secours
et justement j'ai pas
oser se soit tenu une réunion de maires
de grandes villes pour examiner ce
problème
d'abord il faut mettre un terme à la
surenchère entre des municipalités
auxquels il est demandé de subvention
des prés toutes sortes de faveur
deuxièmement le statut des clubs
professionnels de football en france
ne correspond plus à la réalité les
clubs de poils de football professionnel
sont des sociétés ou des organisations
commerciales qui encaisse beaucoup
d'argent qui dépensent beaucoup d'argent
et sont régis par la loi 1901
c'est à dire par un type d'organisations
d'associations à but non lucratif ça
c'est une grande affaire qui devra
passer probablement devant le paris où
elle doit passer devant le parlement
avec les maires de toutes les villes et
quelquefois l'arctique est poli n'est
pas normal que nous restions dans cette
situation et si nous voulons sortir si
nous voulons aborder le problème de fond
il faut changer ces situations c'est ce
à quoi je m'emploierai si je suis réélu
maire de marseille ce plan de sauvetage
ma dernière question monsieur de fer
l'impliquent des changements de tête ou
à la tête
et bien pour le moment le comité de
gestion autonome qui était constituée
par les pour les professionnels et
présidé par monsieur d'agostino le
président de l'om n'est pas changé c'est
aux adhérents de l'om qui l'a pas dire
de à pâtir de décider ce qu'ils veulent
faire
vous l'avez unistar que ce n'est pas
monsieur méric qui est venu rendre
visite aujourd'hui comme d'habitude que
c'est monsieur agostino est ce une
indication les jours qui viennent nous
le diront vous avez dit pour le moment
faudra peut-être attendre le mois
d'avril au mois de mai merci au
lendemain des élections
voilà merci monsieur le faire je vous
fais pas dire merci d'avoir été avec
nous merci d'avoir suivi ce journal
depuis le début les nouvelles de jean
claude monchau après le grand échiquier
royal en direct du christian de du
château de christiansborg avec jacques
chancel à demain bonsoir